[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
two
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
two
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
good morning everyone it's time
we're finally gonna see some more of
cyberpunk 2077
we're very excited we're here with the
pre-show then we're all gonna watch it
and then we'll be back again here after
to discuss everything that we've just
seen i'm lucy james joined by
jake decker hello
and tomorrow hussain wins howling
wait that's the wrong game oh i hate to
see it
hate to see it uh guys thank you so much
for joining me bright and early on this
lovely thursday morning
um so we can't we don't really know what
is gonna be
in this night city uh presentation night
city wire
the tweet from cd projekt said uh
well we don't we know it's kind of like
it's gonna be a new trailer fresh
gameplay footage
and a chat with the devs about one game
feature in particular that's
brain dance but we don't really know
what the trail is going to be of
what gameplay footage what sequence
we're going to be seeing
um but i think all of us here have been
in previous cd projekt red presentations
like from the first e3
so jake let's talk a little bit about
your cyberpunk
journey totally so i
decided e3 2018 i think that was the
first showing
uh the first public showing of the game
and that
i know me as well as many others it blew
me away
uh and other than that i saw
the second one which was the the one
where they
showed two different styles of gameplay
and then i actually was able to play it
i can't talk about that yet
but after the stream uh we will or after
the showcase today we will be able to
talk about that in the post show
um but yeah i'm very excited to see what
they have today
yeah it's kind of wild that both you and
tam have played it
and yet you don't know what's going to
be in this presentation you're allowed
to say that you've played it
obviously we're going to be talking
about that in depth because i have got
a lot of questions tam what are you
hoping to see from the presentation
today
yeah i think um what i'm hoping to see
it will be
uh kind of more of the open world uh i
know jake this is something that he's
keen on talking about as well but so i'm
going to
stick specifically to the quest outside
of the main one that we've seen
so for i was in the first demo for the
game when it was announced and also the
one
after that where they showed more off of
it and it was generally the same section
of the game the
the kind of early uh kind of rescue the
lady from the bathtub scene
so and that is predominantly what we've
seen i'm hoping that we get a little
more time just out in night city in
various districts and
and see a little bit of the um side
quests that you can do or maybe just
some of the incidental stuff that's
happening in the city
um like you said earlier we have played
it so
um but we can't talk about that stuff
but we have no idea what's going to be
in this presentation
so i'm interested to see what they show
there's a it's a big and ambitious game
um based on what they've talked about
and shown previously
and there's a lot of things they could
show but there's also a lot of things
they could
choose to leave out so i'm excited to
see the things that they want people to
pay attention to
right now for cyberpunk
i mean i think the big one is gonna be
for at least for me
keanu reeves would definitely love to
see some more johnny silverhand
but let's talk about when we all first
saw the game because i've also been in
those presentations you know behind
closed doors
it's kind of wild the way that cd
projekts always show off their games
they always do in a very hands-off
manner so it's just like
you get a feel for what the world is i
guess you get a feel
for i don't know like what the
what the combat actually feels like to
play so for me i'm hoping to get a
better
um kind of i want to know what that
gameplay loop is going to look like
obviously we've seen like full missions
through but i want to know what uh what
down time looks like in particular i
definitely want to see
more of keanu reeves um
but also i think tam like what you said
i want to get i want to see those side
quests i want to get lost in that world
i think we all want to get lost in a
different world right now
um jake when you saw that first
presentation what was it that really
caught your eye about cyberpunk like
what was it that
you know it's it's obviously the
follow-up to the witcher 3
one of your favorite games but like what
was it about cyberpunk in particular
i mean i think the biggest thing for me
was how dense it seemed
how dense and how like the the
incredible
attention to detail uh and that's
something cd projekt red is known for
right like with the witcher 3 there's so
much detail in that game even though the
world is so vast
but i'm curious to see exactly what
this world is going to look like on like
the very
small level like i i wanna i hope today
we get to see just kind of walking
around night city and seeing
the the different the different people
you'll see on the street the characters
you might meet
uh the the interesting stories that kind
of play out in front of you that aren't
necessarily
scripted or that aren't necessarily like
key story moments because
especially in this setting like night
city i feel like is
the star of this game um from what we've
seen so far
so i just want to see more of it tam
what about you
yeah i think for me i'm really
interested kind of links into the
sidequest stuff i'm really interesting
interested in seeing or wanting to see
how
far cd projekt com has come in terms of
their writing and
in terms of the compelling things quests
and that kind of stuff in the game
obviously we got
the witcher 3 is one of the best games
of all time but it took them two other
games to kind of reach that point
um and the early witcher games are great
for a lot of reasons but you can really
see the ramp up in the quality of
writing
and the kind of ambition of the story
that they want to tell
so that's kind of been like their
training their rocky montage of training
and now it feels like the witcher 3
ended with cd projekt red
you know establishing itself as some of
the best rpg writers in the world right
now
i'm interested to see how they take that
experience and that new
kind of quality bar that they've set and
whether they're able to
match it from the outset with um
cyberpunk
they have a lot of material to work with
this is the same as you know um
the uh the witcher novels but way more
dense
so i'm excited to see how evident it is
that they are still that kind of
very you know powerhouse of writing or
whether we will have something that's
completely different and it's a little
more
perhaps familiar in terms of an action
game so
um i hope to see some nuances and and
that's what excites me about this kind
of
what i want to see out of cyberpunk well
i mean speaking of
um as you mentioned there kind of the
world to already build on
a lot of games like cyberpunk games
sci-fi in particular
they kind of live or die by the fiction
that has been created and if that world
feels realistic and in cyberpunk's
gazebz you have mike pondsmith's uh
tabletop games to work from jake you've
actually spoken to pondsmith
in the past um what's his
let's talk a little bit more about his
involvement because it's if you think
about the relationship
between uh the man who wrote the witcher
books and the witcher games
a little bit different uh compared to
pondsmith who is
all in on cyberpunk yeah so
uh he actually stopped by the office
about a year and a half ago two years
ago maybe and we got to chat with him
just about like what cyberpunk
is to him like what it was like creating
it and how much involvement he has
in cyberpunk 2077 and while he was
kind of vague it sounds like they have
him in the studio fairly often i mean
maybe not right now because
there's not a lot of travel going on but
they have him in the studio pretty often
just to like
just just for advice and a lot of times
it sounded like it was just to check
things like you'd be like hey does this
thing we're doing right here makes sense
in this world and he'd be like well
yes but maybe this would align more with
what i had in my head or what
would make more sense in this situation
and it sounds like they'll kind of
adjust based on that um but i mean
another thing
too like what we've seen so far and
having played the cyberpunk
tabletop rpg and having read a lot of
that that fiction i guess
uh there's like you can tell cd projekt
red has done
a lot of research um in terms of what
what that world should look like um but
yeah
it seems like he is very close with the
development team in terms of
how to make this world feel like a
cyberpunk 2020
world you know 57 years in the future
when it's 2077.
definitely um let's talk a little bit
about
some of the gameplay options i guess in
that first
uh in that first demo from a couple
years ago it was very you know very
action focused
we got to look at um you know rescuing
that
character and then um like all the med
tech and all that kind of stuff
uh you gotta look at the ripperdoc how
do you think you're gonna play
cyberpunk because in the in the other
demo they showed kind of two builds they
showed like the netrunner build which is
more stealth
and hacking and then the other and then
the other one was you know all guns
blazing so tam
i know you're a stealth boy how do you
think yeah
so i i'm gonna live up to my
uh kind of reputation and go full self
with it i'm
interested to see how far they they'll
allow you to go
obviously the idea of stealth in a
in a game where you can augment your
various body parts and
give yourself strange new technology to
make your
way of life easiest is incredibly
exciting like
i'd love there still hasn't been a game
or there still hasn't been many games
that are as fun as you know playing
metal gear solid for
the second time with the stealth
camouflage suit and just basically being
invisible the entire time
and not a lot of games have that have
the world and the setup to enable that
cyberpunk is one of them where that is
feasible for the first time in a long
time i'm excited about the potential i
hope they've included some sort of
gadget or something that basically
renders you invisible in this game
um i'd love to be able to do that um so
i am going to be playing stealth
um i'm going to try and do my best to do
a no kill
run um i know they've talked about in
previous
kind of gameplay demonstrations that uh
incapacitating enemies is also an option
instead of just outright killing them
so uh wherever possible i i think
you know given that they they talked
about making sure that everyone's play
styles are
um enabled and available to them i'm
gonna go for a silent no kill run
all the way oh hell yeah
um jake what about you i'm gonna do
netrunner i think just because that
seems
so different from that seems like a path
that's so different from most games rpgs
and whatnot
uh i just want to you know after seeing
that
gameplay demo of the netrunner at last
e3 i'm just excited to see how much you
can mess with
the world mess with npcs uh mess with
the environment uh because like the only
game i can think of that has like a
sort of hacking mechanic at least a
triple a game is watchdogs
and that was more of just like just like
here you can do these
fun little things but i'm curious to see
how deep it's gonna be
um because that just seems like a
totally unique way
to play a game yeah i was gonna say
watch dogs was very much
uh gave you the opportunity to hack into
the environment hack into
very very specific things it would be
like a mobile phone
or for some reason the uh bollards on a
street
which was they usually i don't know
i'm not gonna question watch dogs is
game logic but i agree with you i am
very
interested in just seeing like what the
actual limit is like how [ __ ] we push
this game
um i want to kind of take i love taking
a sort of dishonest approach to things
and just trying things out that you
don't
and get those unexpected combinations um
so one thing that we know they are
talking about today which kind of ties
into all this is
brain dance um which is according to
cyberpunk wiki is a kind of personal
version
of the internet and so you can kind of
put your
like a mix of virtual reality you can
kind of put your memories on there so it
kind of feels to me like
um you know that episode of futurama
where they'll put on the headsets and
they'll go into the internet
that part i'm thinking of and then the
other part is kind of like
um i don't know like downloading
memories onto something
sort of similar to maybe like a
westworld thing i'm very interested to
see
more of this and i kind of bet that
there will be some point in this game
where you have to play through someone
else's memories that they've downloaded
into you i guess but yeah
very interesting how that kind of works
um oh no
we know things uh but um
based on yeah i think i think the thing
that we can say
is um not at all involving
our kind of play through there's
definitely more
variety i mean like you can read up on
this and there's something that i did
before i even got anywhere near the game
is it seems like they're trying to make
sure that a variety of interesting
gameplay mechanics are in there
underlying like the the foundation
of the game is very much this open kind
of
pick your playstyle type of approach to
um
to to figuring out you know stealth or
or
combat focused or hacking but they
do want to enable stuff beyond that and
it makes sense given the world and the
opportunities that
you know augmenting your body would
provide you know we've seen stuff like
jackie um holding up that car i'm not
saying you can do that but like
hacking things and turning things
against themselves so i think
fundamentally it is a
kind of um immersive sim with various
rpg mechanics on there but they are
trying to do more of their
of on top and braindance is one of those
things we can probably dig into
what braindance is later but i hope that
they show
more of the the interesting stuff that
they have planned uh
off during during the stream
jake um yeah i i just wanted to add
about brain dance
like in the in the lore like there's a
lot of interesting stuff
behind it like people get addicted to it
because they just kind of get lost
in that world because it's so real and
they're people who just spend
like days and days and days if not weeks
in these memories that they have or in
for example
porn situations um
and i'm curious to see jacob
i know but welcome to i can't wait to go
it's gotta be in it right uh so so i'm
curious to see like
what they do with the characters who are
addicted to that kind of thing or or if
it even plays that much of a role
um but yeah i'm curious to see what they
do lore wise with that because i think
it could be super interesting
yeah definitely i'm i'm very excited
just to see
because i i don't really have that much
experience with the
uh look with cyberpunk red at all um we
never played it we did say in the office
we're gonna get a group together and i
guess now that the game's been delayed
we've got a little bit more time
i'm just saying yeah you can set up a
group um
so i'm very excited to see that and i'm
i'm love
kind of like a sci-fi futuristic that
kind of stuff and so
i'm very excited to see what it pulls
from i know they've said that blade
runner is obviously going to be a big
inspiration for them it's one of my
favorite from all time i'm very excited
to see
just how it it's all inspiring
working together so i'm very excited for
that um i mentioned the delay there so
let's talk a little bit about that
were you guys surprised about the delay
the other another delay time were you
i don't think i was surprised like i
i i me it makes sense to me like it
doesn't
i'm glad that they delayed it i'm glad
that they were open about the fact that
they needed to delay it
i would rather them i mean it's not
exactly the hottest take but you know
the the quote about a bad game is bad
all the time a
good you know delayed game can be good
or whatever the phrasing is from i
believe it water said it um
or myanmar or one of the nintendo folks
um yeah myanmar i believe it was um
and that's very much the approach you
want to take and
given the ambition of the game and the
stuff that they've shown so far
i can't imagine the amount of moving
parts that they need to
get perfectly right all the gears that
they need to get aligned and oiled so
everything runs super slick and super
smooth
this is an open world game um and you
know the witcher 3 came out in a pretty
good state but it was also a game that
required a little extra
kind of time not time in the oven but
tweaks and bits and pieces here and
there and i imagine cd projekt red are
learned a lot from that and we're like
you know let's try and get into an even
better position so that we've got less
work to do when the game is finally out
and if they need to take the extra time
to do that all for it
um at the end of the day the game is
gonna come out
at some point and you just want the
developers to feel confident that the
thing they put out is
the best it can be given the time that
they had
yeah jake i know the game was originally
supposed to launch on your birthday
um how do you feel about waiting a
couple more months
uh i mean that one stung the most the
delay from my birthday because when they
announced it at e3 i was so excited i
was like this is gonna be
the best birthday ever and then it got
delayed
uh to september and i was pretty bummed
uh mostly because it was like it wasn't
just like a month or two
it was like half a year or what seemed
like half a year i don't know what that
is five months
whatever uh so this next by the time
this next delay happened i was just kind
of like okay
you know i'm i'm with i'm with you guys
i want
i want this game to be as free as rel as
possible like obviously
you know it's tough to squash every bug
in a game this big and i'm sure people
are going to find
bugs and funny situations and whatnot
that happen as they play it when the
game comes out
but i i also think cd projekt red is
very aware that that like
games like this games of like these
like like skyrim for example like almost
as synonymous
bethesda is synonymous with their bugs
and i don't think they want that and i
wouldn't want that either you know so
i'm i'm cool with waiting an extra
couple months if they delayed again
that would hurt but i can wait i can
wait i can do it
and i think as well definitely the move
to working from home
like obviously it's impacted our jobs
and
we definitely took a few weeks to figure
out how to make everything happen from
home
so imagine that on a wild scale with
game development
i can't even imagine the hoops that they
would have had to jump through to make
that all work from home
so i think a delay probably on my i
expected it um and honestly a couple
months
that's fine and they've said now that
it's in line
with you know the launch of brand new
consoles so xbox series x
and playstation 5 which they were gonna
do
what was it like the game was gonna
continue over anyway if you were gonna
be playing it on current gen
um so i guess are you guys gonna get
uh next-gen consoles day one and then
start your
cypher playthrough on those or are you
gonna wait a little bit for a console
and just kind of move your save over
time i'll go to you well i just
bought a brand new pc for this game so
i i think i mean like i bought a brand
new pc for many games but i was
i think i'm gonna play it on pc maybe um
i think i'll end up double dipping just
because i want to see what it's like
on a i mean pc gaming is always you know
the same kind of experience i want
something to kind of uh stress test
consoles and this feels like a good game
to do that
um so i imagine i'll be double dipping
getting it on pc and then also maybe
either of ps4 or um xbox series x
depending on
how things are looking when the game's
out and people have started reporting on
which
performance wise is better um
so i i reckon i'll probably end up
playing on console and
and on pc and i think that might be a
good way to do a kind of multi-run
two different approaches i i want to do
stealth but i feel more comfortable
doing stealth on
on a console where i can sit down and be
deliberate and take my time and use a
controller whereas when i have a mouse
and keyboard
i want to flick the wrist and you know
pop headshots and
and be aggressive and move around and
and be like active and dynamic and play
um so i imagine i i that's a good
opportunity to
to you know play two different styles
and have fun with it
jake what about you yeah i mean i'm
kind of with tamora i just built a pc i
put a 280 ti
in there with like it's i spared almost
no expense
on this pc with the thought that like
yeah when cyberpunk comes out
that's what i'm gonna play on but like
tomorrow i will probably also double dip
i mean i own the witcher 3 on
gog steam uh xbox one
switch ps4 like i imagine i'll probably
end up doing something very similar
and probably just to replay it and try
different things and
see how it runs and whatnot but i think
primarily it's gonna be
uh pc and also like two like the witcher
3
ran great on all consoles uh i mean
you know there are frame rate dips and
whatnot but playing on pc is like
eye-opening with that game because it
runs so much better it looks so much
crisper
uh the detail is so much better the the
hair effects are wild
on pc so i'm very excited to see what
they do
with the pc version of this game because
knowing cd projekt red they'll probably
it'll it'll look great um so i'm very
excited to see
that oh this is making
i would i was gonna play on a console
just because
i mean i have my pc here too but like
my big tv i've got my bed over there but
i think the thing that i need to bear in
mind i don't know about you guys is but
for multiplayer which
uh cd projekt have confirmed it's not
going to be there at launch but
i obviously want to be playing where my
friends are do you think we're going to
get more details about multiplayer today
tam i honestly don't think so and i
would be surprised if
this i don't have any evidence of this
this is all speculation in my mind
if if if like the game the multiplayer
component of the game is part of
cyberpunk 2077 in in terms of like you
launch that executable or on a console
launch that game and go into it
my my thought is my suspicion is that
i'll be a completely separate
like game that they'll release
standalone and and kind of allow you to
to experience that separate from the
main game
and maybe it'll carry over some
character stuff or this and that but
i feel like that'll be detached from the
current experience
um especially since it's being developed
in in kind of like
distinctly from the main game as is and
is that a different studio and that kind
of stuff
um i think it might be kind of its own
thing
in which case like um there's it just
means that we'll i'll have that
make that decision later on downline but
i don't think we're going to see
anything from my player for a long time
jake what about what do you think yeah i
agree
i i think i think it'll be
i think it'll be a while i think at
least i don't know i don't i don't want
to guess but but i bet it would be at
least at the very least a couple months
before we hear anything
about multiplayer after the game
launches uh
and like as for what it could be i'm
picturing
like a very much like a gta online but
cyberpunk
style multiplayer um so i'm very curious
to see what they do with it and this
will also be
cd projekt red's like first big attempt
at a multiplayer experience
because i know i know they've got gwent
um which is multiplayer
but i'm very curious to see what a cd
projekt red world will be like shared
with friends
yeah tam i think i was going to say i
think
i think they might actually go for this
is pure speculation like try and emulate
the actual
tabletop game a little more then they
would do it in it i think it's going to
pull back a bit and be
surprisingly different um i think the
gta style approaches
it makes sense in the mind but i don't
know if it makes sense in in the actual
kind of
game itself like it can you accommodate
what that game is and what they present
it as like this in-depth rpg experience
while also maintaining a multiplayer in
this kind of
environment like i i kind of feel like
it doesn't
match that way i feel like there's a
little more of a opportunity to pull the
camera back or pull the whole gameplay
experience back a bit and
and do um like something closer to the
tabletop experience because
there's a lot of charm and a lot of a
lot to love in the tabletop experience
and i imagine a
massive number of people who are going
to be playing this game haven't have
played that
could be an opportunity for them to kind
of funnel people into that and
give them new parts of this cyberpunk
world and new ways to experience it
yeah that would be really cool i think
now that you mentioned that i definitely
prefer that i'm just thinking of like
i don't know starting campaigns with
friends and like i don't know some of
them are kind of longer in each campaign
you can build a different character if
you want and just kind of
test that out with friends like that
would be that would be awesome
yeah yeah i'm i'm really intrigued as to
what that's going to look like but we
actually have
we got about four minutes until the
stream so let's start talking just a
little bit about
hopes and dreams from this one um
are we hoping for another breathtaking
appearance from keanu reeves
tim absolutely i hope that he's in there
i suspect again that they won't put them
in there like i feel like they've done
the
they've done the mic drop and they can't
pick the mic up and drop it again
maybe they can uh cd projekt red is bold
enough to do that
but i feel like they've they've done the
tease and now they're done with it
if we're more likely to get like someone
else
famous show up then another keanu reeves
um
appearance in this i would love to see
more johnny silverhands
um but i suspect not
oh so yeah because we had the grimes
reveal at the game awards last year
uh music by refused to
god who else could they possibly get i
would i would want it to be someone
really left field
like gilbert gottfried or someone just
thought
in cyberpunk 2077
jake what do you think is it is it time
for more breathtaking keanu
i mean i would love to see more kiana
but the one thing that i kind of want to
see more of that i hope we see is the
relationship stuff because they did
mention that like the way relationships
are going to work in this are very
different than the witcher and that's
something i don't think a lot of people
are probably curious in that but i'm
i want to see like how that works
yeah well yeah i'm interested to see
that because i want to know if it's
going to be
i don't know like uh i don't think it's
going to be sort of a gauge like the
sims
like you move from friend to best friend
or whatever but i am interested to see
um more of that more of the relationship
building i want to see more characters
from that world we've seen
you know little brief snippets of who v
will be interacting with on their
journey um
i think tam like it goes back to what
you said earlier it's all about
the smaller stories the ones that really
resonate i really hope to see more of
today
we have like a minute and a half until
the stream um
one minute 15 seconds actually so i'm
gonna wrap this up and tell you a little
bit about what we're gonna have
after the stream so jake and tomorrow
have played it
which has been wild because they didn't
they don't actually know what's in this
presentation so
this has been a real curveball for them
on a thursday morning uh we're gonna be
talking about their impressions
how cyberpunk actually feels to play
the levels that they played through um
what else do we have we have
uh an interview going up tomorrow with
cd projekt red two features over the
weekend jake do you want to speak very
quickly about those
yeah so once covering what we know about
the story so far
and then one is covering how the game
feels and how it's played
awesome um okay we've got about 30
seconds
yeah and time you've got written
impressions going up on gamespot.com but
uh don't forget to come here right after
the cyberpunk uh night city wire
i think it's the first they're gonna do
a few of these uh don't forget to come
back here afterwards we're gonna be
talking through what we've seen
and how cyberpunk feels to play so don't
go anywhere
all right we've got a city to burn let's
do this
[Music]
hello and welcome to this the very first
episode of night city wire
a brand new series from us at cd projekt
red where we'll be talking
about all things cyberpunk 2077.
for today's episode we'll be starting
with a brand new trailer
one of our developers will be joining us
to help unpack everything you're going
to see
we'll have some news an announcement
about a secret collaboration
we'll be taking a look at some brain
dance gameplay and welcoming back our
developers just to have a chat about
everything you're going to see
but there is one more thing media all
over the world have been getting
hands-on with cyberpunk 2077
and when this episode finishes you'll be
able to go and check out exactly what
they thought
so let's get started it is time to take
a look at our brand new trailer
and after that our lead quest designer
pavel sasco will be joining
us because i've got a feeling you're
gonna have a few questions after
watching this
so let's take a look
i love this town a city of endless
opportunity
ready to get your cherry popped yeah
come on
city like any other just bigger
no no not just any other city legends
are born here
the major leagues we're only here
because dex is pulling the strings
doubt that puts us in the same league as
them but we are
they just don't know it yet but if you
got the cojones
and you know how to use them you could
do damn near anything
unless you catch a bull even then you go
out with a bang
right you know you can make heaps more
eddies as a motivational speaker
yo mr v a pleasure so what's the gate
dicks you meant to come out in one piece
[Laughter]
how about we go over the plan there's
this
prototype tech biochip to be precise
jobs to grab it guessing it belongs to a
court
arasaka we are robbing some heavy
hitters thought you could blackmail me
[ __ ]
high risk have a war first rule of the
afterlife
baby goes without saying we do this on
the hush
ideally no bodies not a one
sounds simple enough
[ __ ] is it gonna be dangerous
don't you worry miami we're bulletproof
get your ass moving now
what the [ __ ] just happened in there i
can't stop digging night city
[ __ ] happy now jackie yeah
that's [ __ ] high oh my god we're so
[ __ ]
dicks what the [ __ ] can't rescue me
and you who are you
[ __ ]
so the trailer contains footage from the
game's prologue only
but there was an awful lot in it so
pavel why don't you
try and help us unpack everything that
we just saw oh yeah i mean absolutely i
can try so
what you have just seen is only the
prologue of the game so
that awesome stuff is only happening in
the first few quests
what the trailer show you do is really
our stage
the night city you know this gigantic
city build of
six completely unique districts
surrounded by the seventh one that we
call the badlands
as a player you are meeting jackie jack
is your friend now
they together are trying to reach out
for
something that is very precious they are
trying to reach out for this
ship of immortality this gateway to
eternal life
jackie introduces you to fixer dexter
desean
he's a very important person in a social
ladder of cyberpunk
he is able to provide the player with
various jobs and contracts
to be able to gather money to be able to
modify their bodies push themselves to
the limits
to put their hands on the chip but as
you can expect not everything goes as
planned
and uh but to to see it you will have to
play the game
there are an awful lot of really cool
things in this trailer and there's a few
that i would just love to talk about a
little bit more for the people at home
so let's start with talking about a gang
called the mox now we see a few flashes
of them in this trailer
i personally think they're really cool
and one of my favorites but
can you give us a little bit more
information about them oh yes so
the mox is one of the gangs that player
is going to interact with throughout the
game
the mox is the gang that has been formed
in 2076
after death of elizabeth borden she was
called lizzy
now she was an owner of a brothel and
former
sex worker and she was protecting
working
guys and girls from harassment from
abuse and the gang is really continuing
her mission
and as a player you are going to
interact with that gang meet
multiple different npcs and craft your
own relationship with them
and understand what they're all about so
earlier on you did mention
a seventh district a place called the
badlands now we saw a few shots of this
in the trailer but i'd love for you to
give us a bit more detail about the
district outside
of the city walls okay so the badlands
is this like
dead dried out space going around the
whole night city
and as a player you'll be able to
traverse that space in your car and
motorcycle
this is a space that is inhabited by the
nomads nomads are living in a different
families
and are traveling across that space in
convoys
made out of the cars and motorcycles and
as a player
you will be able to traverse and access
different type of open world content
that has been
prepared specifically for you to that
get that awesome feel of the badlands as
an area
in the trailer we also saw like a
completely metal creature now he didn't
look like he was from the maelstrom gang
this looked like
something else so please tell the people
at home who is this
giant metal monster okay so so the big
dude that was
adam smasher he has been introduced in a
pen and paper in cyberpunk 2020
by our senpai mike pondsmith
adam smasher is a fully converted cyborg
he is he was always a loyalist of
arasaka
and time has changed and in 2077 he had
to
find his own space in night city
but to uh find out you'll have to play
the game
in this trailer we do see some flashes
of a ripper dock called victor vector i
think if people have watched our
previous game plays they might remember
him
but i'd really like for you to give the
people at home some more information
about
what ripper docks are and how they'll be
interacting with them when they play
cyberpunk
so reaper dogs in our game they are
surgeons they are like a specific type
of a
job in the social ladder of cyberpunk
they are accustomed and specialized in
replacing limps uh to the metal ones
they can basically update your
body enhance your body change you into
this walking war machine
and as a player you are going to meet
different kind of reaper dogs in
in the game craft your own relationship
with them some of them are
like important characters for a for a
story through that you will invest
uh eddie's that you're gathering to turn
your body into this tool that allows you
to survive on the streets of night
season
pavel thank you so much for joining us i
know you'll be back later in the episode
because you're going to be helping us to
analyze the brain dance gameplay
but before that we do have some news to
share
earlier in the year we announced that if
you pick up cyberpunk 2077
on xbox one you'll be able to play it on
xbox series
x when the console launches and just in
case you missed it it will be the same
for playstation players as well
if you pick up cyberpunk 2077 on
playstation 4
you'll also be able to play it on
playstation 5 when the console launches
and that's not all there will be a free
upgrade for xbox series x
and playstation 5 but we'll have more
details on that soon tonight city
before we reveal our first look at the
braindance gameplay and welcome back our
developers for a chat
there is just one more thing we want to
announce something that we've been
working on in secret for a while
we are very excited to announce our
partnership with studio trigger and
netflix to bring you cyberpunk
edgerunners
a standalone anime set in the cyberpunk
universe which
we've been working on for some time now
edgerunners is due to launch in 2022
but for some more information let's go
to the team in tokyo
hi my name is saya elder i am the japan
based producer for cyberpunk edge
runners
what i do basically on this project is
that i
am a fixer to put it in the words of the
cyberpunk universe
we are a game company we are a bunch of
nerds and wherever there are nerds
there's gonna be anime fans
so it's was always a dream for us to
make
anime when we began this project we
were certain that we didn't want to make
a recreation of the game
cyberpunk edge runners is a standalone
story
set in the same universe the stage is
still night city
but everything else is totally new new
characters
new story i do like to think that it's
going to be
a great gateway for newcomers to come
and check cyberpunk game and also the
cyberpunk genre as a whole
right now we're in nakano which is one
of the biggest anime umekas of the world
i'm going to take you to studio trigger
right now because we have the wonderful
opportunity to talk to the dream team
that will be bringing you this anime
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
me
now it's time to show you some gameplay
of braindance this is a feature that
you'll experience when you play
cyberpunk 2077
braindance is essentially a recording of
somebody else's experience
it allows you to relive their sense of
scythe smell
touch and even hearing all thanks to a
special device
after the gameplay i will be welcoming
back pavel sasco
i will also be joined by patrick mills
our senior quest designer and all-round
law master
who will be helping to answer your
questions and give you some explanation
on how you'll be interacting with brain
dance when you play cyberpunk 2077
so let's take a look
plant simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in
snatch the cash get out and we sell the
pd to those psycho freaks
studio got it got it and remember
everything on full blast they'll spot us
extra for a wicked adrenaline high
okay on you go
down everybody on the ground i want to
see you kissing the flooring
money now where i will [ __ ] drop you
i swear to god
well yeah hey now before i blow your
[ __ ] head off
slow deep breaths your cortisol and
adrenaline spiked but the soft activated
your hormone blockers nothing happened
you're alive and well that was
too much i felt it could feel the guy's
pain his stress his
hope hope wrapped up in something else
probably took a booster just before
you'll be fine
got everything set up let's switch over
to editing mode
i'll sever the link to the bd roller's
sensory array
you'll be able to look around freely the
whole scene's yours
full cam control and analysis mode so
move around
zoom in and out whatever else you come
up with think of it as your own little
sandbox so analysis mode
you control playback can even pause when
you feel the need
then you use the editor console to
unpause try it
plan simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go
in snatch the cash get out and we sell
the bd to those psycho freaks from the
studio
got it got it dream as hell right well
that's not all
you can speed things up or rewind
whatever you like
give it a try rewind roll it back to the
top
all good neat now try fast forwarding a
bit
plan
okay you can also reset the recording
that'll take you right back to the
beginning
try it
now for some fun this here's why you
came in the first place
in analysis mode you get to view and
even scan details of the enviro recorded
by the bd roller
focus on the heat the gun this gunk gets
from his buddy at the beginning
okay right here
excellent let's move on
now heads up in analysis mode you can
ferret out background noise and
conversations if the roller got close
enough
this tag records everything every little
detail
even the sights and sounds the roller
was never aware of
to see the sources of the recorded
sensory signals switch to the audio
layer in the editor
go ahead and try that now okay good
now you should see several sound
signatures in the store
choose one and hone in on it
pack of six case of broseph and a couple
of zappers
okay we have a deal today on two flavors
cuddy everybody so
any thoughts unbelievable seriously
like what's happening right next to me
yeah it's how bd recording implants work
they pick up everything all the elements
in the background
then an editor tweaks them makes them
pop keep playing with the sound
explore it a bit we'll move on when you
get bored
when i see you kissing the flooring
money
sometimes you can analyze extra layers
in the raw stuff the rollers cyberware
picked up
like what eb's got kiroshi optics that
grab infrared
meaning you should be able to grab heat
signatures from her recording
hello nice scanning works on peeps too
walk up to the wounded chick try
scanning her
all right next thing scroll forward to
the part where our artist gets a nut
injection
where i will [ __ ] drop you i swear it
is
see that they shot him and he never saw
it coming
but you will here it comes my favorite
part of the game
see the blinking thing over the entrance
surveillance cam
must have caught our shooter you'll see
in a sec
cam feeds to the screen behind the clerk
roll back to where the screens in the
kids field of vision
then scan it
his own chumba shot him probably planned
to all along
must have got a nice slice of cred on
the black market for a bd like this
bd freaks are ready to pay a prem for a
real flatline
anyway if you've seen enough you can
exit
yeah it's impressive right it's too bad
most of the bds we do here are only good
for flogging the log
so braindance is a pretty big part of
the cyberpunk universe it's not just
something used for adult films there is
an awful lot to it
and there's two sides i'd really like
you guys to help me explore
first is the law so how this actually
fits into the universe and then there's
the gameplay side so how players will be
interacting with it
so patrick could you tell us more about
the law of brain dance
i would love to uh so in the world of
cyberpunk
2077 braindance was invented way back in
the early 2000s at uc santa cruz
it was developed as a way of recording a
person's experiences
and then playing them back for someone
else as so that they could relive them
as though it was happening to them it
was originally used for things like
therapy
and prisoner rehabilitation but by 2077
it's become this global media industry
including things like movies
mass entertainment things like that
video games some interactive things and
of course
adult fare as well now in our game we
deal a lot with
black brain dances or xbds as we call
them and there are different types of
those
but the one that you saw in the trailer
just there was a flatliner now that's
where
the person recording it actually dies
during the recording
and it's popular sort of illicit kind of
a thrill
but a mercenary can also use them for
various things and you'll see that in
the game of course and from the gameplay
perspective
we have been working a lot throughout
last year's
trying to figure out the best way how to
use the braindance in the game as a
mechanics
so what we have settled on is this
brandon's editor mode
as a player you will be able to run the
braindance
in the editor mode and see different
clues
that have been registered on the
peripheral of
given actor now as a player you can
slide on the timeline of the recording
back and forth trying to uncover
different clues
and that clues are actually telling a
story in the game
so as a player you will run different
investigations that will lead you
to uh different mysteries and you will
uncover them actually using that
braindance
as a mechanics in the game so as pavel
was saying
we use braindance as a storytelling tool
it's not a collectible it's not
something where you're going to go in
and you're going to play it and you're
going to be like i've seen this before
what we use braindance for
is to give you a keyhole into the life
of the residents of night city
and we can explore things like childhood
trauma religion
various philosophical ideas in a way
that you might not otherwise experience
in a story about a mercenary on the
tough streets
so we've tried to talk about some of the
aspects that we think the community will
find really exciting but
you know while you're both here i'd love
to know what is it about cyberpunk that
you guys are really excited for
uh patrick why don't you start so one of
the things that i'm most excited about
in this game
is the characters and the way they
interact with the world
we've got this really interesting world
that stretches all the way back to the
cyberpunk 2020 source material
and all of these events and all those
things but those don't mean anything
unless they connect with characters and
so when we come up with a character we
start with their function
what is this person what do they do in
the story but we don't stop there we go
back and we figure out what was their
childhood like what was their upbringing
like
what kind of obstacles did they face in
this harsh reality
and did they overcome them and how did
they overcome them or did they not
overcome them
why and you can see all of those things
in their environment in their dialogues
in sort of how they operate in the world
and we come up with that for
all of our characters now you look at
someone like victor vector
and you're going to see stories about
his past
in his environment and in his dialogue
you know we come up with that stuff
even if we don't use it in the game
because it helps inform us
as to who these characters are and uh
for me
i would not be myself if i would not say
that i'm the most excited about
our quests like with our witcher 3 team
with patrick and
like everybody that has stayed with us
since the witcher 3 time
we really have grown so much uh we have
learned so much and
we have used all that experience to put
them
into the quest that we have made and you
will not find really
a filler in this game like everything
has a meaning like we
put so much effort into making sure that
everything
is rewarding it's interesting it's
talking about characters as patrick said
he's talking about
worlds it's talking about emotions like
touching the player in a really
like a real way um and i just
can't wait to find out what you think
pavel i know you mentioned story and
quests and writing quests and
when i was last in the studio i had a
look and i saw a notebook on your desk
and i would love for you to show
everybody this notebook okay golly i
mean
you asked for it so this is my notebook
it says a
salsa quest designer uh the reason is
because i then salsa
and i'm a quest designer so you know so
so i
wrote started this notebook actually
when we were really starting cyberpunk
at the very beginning i wrote
like a first note and it says pretty
much something around along the lines of
that we're starting with a prototype and
then you know i kept on
basically noting things that we've been
working on um for like next year's
i remember once when our concept artists
actually approached me
and they said that they want to take a
look at my notebook i was like
what for actually and they they took
some pictures
um and they told me yeah well you know
because we are looking for a
reference material for a uh notes of a
psychopathic killer
so so uh yeah well you may
find maybe some of my notes in the game
pavel and patrick thank you so much for
joining me i'm pretty lucky because i
have read some of the stories that you
and the team have written for braindance
and i'm
pretty excited for people to discover
them but uh before we do finish today's
episode there is just
one more thing we'd like to talk about
earlier in this episode i mentioned that
media have been getting hands-on with
the opening of cyberpunk 2077
and they should be posting their
impressions right about now
and if you missed anything from today's
episode don't worry we'll be uploading
everything to our channels very soon
and finally on behalf of everybody at cd
projekt red
we just want to say thank you so much
for joining us for this very first
episode of night city wire
but don't worry we'll be back with
episode 2 in just a few weeks
so we shall see you soon
well welcome back everyone um i'm just
gonna get
right into it because now you guys are
free to talk about
actually playing cyberpunk take do you
want to take it away jake
what what from that presentation had you
already seen
so i i hadn't seen a lot of that in my
playthrough because
i was kind of messing around so i just
explored night city
i was messing around with npcs the
environment and whatnot
however i did see a lot of that in uh
some b-roll they had sent over so i was
very familiar with what we saw
for the most part there's a lot of
there's a lot of other stuff in there
but like i guess just top level
impressions based on what i played
it seems like a i i hate comparing it to
things but it reminded me a lot of gta
but with very heavy rpg elements just
in like how it felt walking around this
giant city with
pedestrians walking around in the way
you'd hop in a car
and you'd switch to third-person mode
and drive around the city going to
different objectives
but the big thing that really stood out
to me that i'm
really excited to see more of is just
how dense and populated
the city is and how
and and how much detail there is there
like i spent so much time
just like i had a developer with me
and he i could not just follow one path
i'd drive i don't know probably like 20
meters and i'd be like oh and i'd hop
out of my car
and i'd check out a little side alley
and it would open up into this big
marketplace
uh where there'd be tons of characters
walking around and there'd be music
blaring and the advertisements are
kind of overwhelming but in a good way
in a way that you
that probably should be the case in a
cyberpunk world
but man yeah top level stuff it is
it reminded me a lot of like a gta
rpg so where did you actually like what
part of the game did you actually play
time so in our demo we played through
we got to pick between one of the uh
starting life paths there's three
there's corporal
uh there is street kid and then there's
nomad
um and we have an impressions video
coming up later on you should see it on
uh youtube.com gamespot on gamespot.com
where
myself jake and ed talk about each of
those paths and the three divergent
styles that we played
but um we we each got to start the game
at the very beginning
pick a life path which is an origin
story think of it in the same way that
you would in dragon age
you pick a you know a starting point for
your character
and then you were basically left to do
what you wanted to do from the outset of
the game so it's the very beginning of
the game
in my play through i decided to follow
the main quest for
a little bit and see where that takes me
and it
for the most part was b4b quite similar
to
last year's gameplay demo where you do
the opening mission where you go to the
apartment
and rescue the lady in the bathtub and
uh
kind of turn her over to the trauma team
to take care of and then
you go you meet dexter desean and then
you start doing the kind of um
maelstrom mission to get the uh the ai
controlled or
mind controlled uh turret bike and it
kind of escalates from that point
um from that point on it kind of
branches off into smaller other you can
do side quests or you can do things that
are
still tied to the main quest but are
like the the main crux of the area the
point the part i was in was a heist
got to go into a certain person's uh
home or
office and steal certain things and
there's a lot of setup to getting that
done
um and part of that setup is the brain
dance
so before we move on to the brain dance
i just have a couple more questions
about
sorry my um jk was saying that you know
you couldn't really go more than 20
meters without kind of being
distracted and wanting to see something
new what's there to keep pushing you
to continue the main story or are you
just free to do whatever you want in
this world
uh so i mean after you pick your origin
story at the beginning i went with nomad
um which started me out in the badlands
uh after you
complete that and you get to night city
there's like a time skip
uh which we didn't get to see what
happens in between they said there's
gonna be a cinematic or some sort of
thing prepared
that'll go over all that kind of stuff
we didn't get to see that they just put
us right into night city
uh where you do a i i believe
you do another quest and then from then
on you go back to your apartment
and it just kind of opens up your
directive is to go to talk to jackie
because he's he he's talking to dexter
desean about a job
however i didn't really do that uh
immediately i walked out of view
i walked out of my apartment went to a
shop bought a knife walked down
and stabbed a night city pd just in the
back to see what would happen
and the the whole crowd started
panicking and people started freaking
out but then from there i just kind of
went in my own direction i really only
explored
one of the major districts i think i saw
bits and pieces of other ones
but i was mostly in i want to say maybe
the city center i forget exactly what
district i was in
um but yeah like to stay
there is like that dotted line um to
different objectives and you can track
quests
just like you could in the witcher but
like i said there was so much
both showing up on my map that were like
distracting not in a bad way but i was
just like ooh this seems interesting
and then there was also other things in
the environment that just
stood out that i was like i have to see
what this is about
oh yeah i mean like you were saying it's
a very
dense world that it looks like um
tam i'm gonna ask you a little bit about
gameplay wise what did it actually feel
like to walk around in
and how did the actually and and also
combat how did that feel
so um i think like to walk around in
it's it's quite i think the the kind of
crux of my preview
that is now live on the site was
everything felt kind of
overwhelming and like jake said earlier
overwhelming in the right way um there
was so much to
it felt like it reminded me of being in
tokyo for the first time
where it felt familiar like the building
blocks of the city were
things that you've seen before but the
sense of just
stimulus coming from literally every
direction
it kind of makes your nerves tingle a
bit and that's where that sense of like
losing not losing focus but not sure
where to
put your focus happens um so like it
felt like a
futuristic metro you know metropolitan
metropolis where you're where you're
just trying to make your way around and
you could like walk around for hours
probably and just kind of drink it in
and and see what happens um
unfortunately we didn't really have
hours to do that so it was just a little
bit of walking around and
there's it is a bustling city with a lot
to stare at and interact with and listen
to and
but the actual gameplay and the shooting
was the kind of main thing that i
suspect not specked into but like ended
up doing
and it felt really really satisfying
even so the one of the things that i
mentioned in my preview is i struggle
with games that
are like rpg shooters loot issues
whatever you want to call them
not a lot of them always hit for me like
feeling good
and feeling satisfying because you're
chipping away at health you're
you know you're shooting at shields that
kind of stuff and although you are kind
of doing that
this feels like it still is satisfying
to do
like a game like borderlands i mentioned
in my preview is one that doesn't quite
work for me
in the same way like a destiny would
because destiny's guns
feel impactful whereas borderlands guns
are cool and quirky but they don't
always have that
that kind of satisfying punch to them
this is a game where
the guns have a satisfying punch to them
when they need to
obviously there are guns that feel a
little lighter and more live
but for the most part everything felt
good to shoot and it felt good to like
shoot at things um even if that meant
you were you were kind of like shooting
at shields or chipping away at health
um at the same time there was a lot of
opportunity to
play in other ways like i did stealth
stuff and it
felt very very viable and i like i said
previously i'm a stealth person
and this game does that really great
thing of when you do a thing
it rewards you for doing the thing so if
you're crouching around and walking
around it
gives you experience for doing that if
you're shooting loads of rifles it gives
you experience for shooting those rifles
if you're hacking loads it gives you
experience for being a hacker
on top of allowing you to spec into it
so like that
at the start of this kind of answer i
mentioned overwhelming and it's
the same for the gameplay as well
there's so much you can think about
there's so much for you to think about
there's so much for you to keep in mind
and spec into
and and that kind of stuff um it just
feels like a
a like meaty game to play
jake how did you find it yeah i mean i'd
say very similar to timur i played as
kind of like a
uh i tried to play as a net runner but
because i was still very early in the
game
i didn't have a lot of abilities i only
was able to hack a couple things and a
couple characters
which was a lot of fun like a hacking
minigame pops up and i actually had a
lot of fun
playing the hacking minigame to the
point where i like wanted to hack
more just because i had fun matching the
numbers
um but as a i don't know i guess a
a early net runner i was mostly botching
a lot of these
experian these hacking things
so i would try to hack i'd maybe hack a
couple things
and then someone would catch my scent
and then i'd go guns blazing
and it was a lot of shooting which i
which
i was cool with because that's something
that's a way that i will probably end up
playing
i did notice like now we played a
preview build an early build so it's not
done
but the shooting didn't feel as precise
as something like destiny or call of
duty
however kind of like timur was saying
like the shooting still felt very
satisfying and i think a lot of that is
due to the fact that these guns
kick like a donkey and um
the the sound effects are really good
like it just feels really satisfying to
shoot things even like
i use the smaller pistol a lot because
my pistol skill was getting high and i
had fun using the pistol
uh and even that like it sure was a
small dinky little pistol but it really
did feel like
i i was like packing iron i was ready to
go
uh so so that was great and then i also
noticed a we played on controller they
didn't want us to use mouse and keyboard
um so we played controller and i did
notice there was a
pretty generous aim assist um
i don't know how much you'll be able to
tweak when the the final game comes out
but
tim yeah i was going to say that we
didn't play on mouse and keyboard
mainly we should say we the the reason
we played with the controller is because
we used
we played through the cloud using a
special um kind of uh
software um and that meant that we
weren't able to engage with
the mouse and keyboard it wasn't a
technical limitation or anything like
that um it was just a matter of the
software would get confused if we were
both trying to import at the same time
using mafia mouse and keyboard and a
controller um
yeah and and so that was the reason we
played on controller but like jake said
um
the controller stuff felt fine it felt
good
um you know shooting with with it
was it had that good sense of feedback
on a controller that you get
um which is the same you know on whether
you're playing
with mouse and keyboard or controller
but yeah i think those who want to play
on massive keyboard or those who play
want to play on controller should be
well taken care of
so one thing i was going to ask
obviously the game is still in
development you're playing through the
cloud so it's
not exactly apples to apples when you're
playing it at home and it's the final
product but how did it run
jake so it ran
pretty smooth uh for me for the most
part in terms of just like
frame rate and all that stuff there are
some crowded areas where it would dip a
little bit
but you know once again we kind of trust
that that stuff will be worked out when
the game comes out and they did delay it
um i did run into bugs uh i did run into
a good amount of bugs nothing
game breaking um but there were
definitely some bugs here and there some
funny ones that that happened
uh i mean you know with games this big
that kind of stuff is bound to happen
like there's
so many i guess funny bugs in the
witcher and whatnot
um but once again you know it's kind of
hard to say what the final release would
be like because they did just delay it
and they said mostly to squash bugs
but overall like i mean streaming it on
pc i have pretty good internet so it
works pretty well in that
sense uh i didn't have any latency or
lag or anything like that but the game
itself
seemed to run pretty well um from what i
could tell i'm definitely excited to
you know when i play this on pc to
really dig into all those settings and
see
how far we'll be able to push this game
before we dig into what we saw in night
city wire are there any
final comments about your your hands on
time or time i'll go to you first
um yeah i think i think the thing that i
walked away from
uh playing it was i just had seen a
fraction of it and it sounds
very much like what they say in the
night ce wire this is just a small piece
of it but it really does feel like
it was a very very small piece of the
game we played for four hours
and i still kind of my mind was racing
with wanting to do 10 different things
at the same time and
you know there's so many parts that you
can take i wanted to stop and try
something reload it and start again but
um
i wasn't able to but i think the the
thing that i'm most excited about is
when people do get their hands on the
game it looks like there's going to be
plenty for us to really dissect and
think about and talk about so that's the
most exciting thing about it for me
right now
jake what about you yeah so there's two
things that i
do want to mention the first is there's
pubic hair customization
found that out in the character creator
because we started out by
doing that which is something that i
like had to double take i was like
i don't know if i actually saw that and
then ed was talking about it too and i
was like okay i did actually see
a pubic hair option i didn't mess with
most of the customization options just
because i didn't want to spend
too much time in the character crater i
wanted to get in and play uh
and then the other thing i want to
mention is that
v has like one thing i noticed that v
has like a
phone essentially i mean it's not called
the phone in the cyberpunk universe i
forget what it's called
but they get messages and whatnot and
i'm curious to see
what kind of role that will play because
i i was getting messages as i played and
i checked those and a lot of times it
would be like
hey we've got a job for you which which
would lead to a quest which i could
track right then and there
but i'm also curious to see how that
will work with characters because there
was some
i could respond to like i didn't pick
what i wanted to say it was just a
predetermined thing i just hit respond
and then v would write something and
send but i'm curious to see like
if that will come into play in a sense
like
like gta 4 did almost where like your
buddies will be like hey do you want to
hang out do you want to go to a bar or
whatnot because
that is something that this game seems
to have a lot of is like what you do
when you're not killing people how you
blow off steam and whatnot
so i'm very curious to see how that's
going to tie into the very different
relationships and characters you meet
throughout the game because
personally i love that stuff in games
and there's like a little phone and
you've got your side conversations going
on
my god i hope there is a reference where
some character asks if you want to go
bowling in that case
it's got to be that has to be
all right so let's talk a little bit
about what we saw in night city wire
so we had some more details from pavel
uh sasco lead quest designer uh talked a
little bit about the districts we got to
see the seventh district which is called
the badlands
big kind of mad max vibes there very
cool
i need to i need to talk about this guy
adam smasher
what an incredible name uh absolutely i
like
i was sad that there was no keanu reeves
but it's fine we had
adam smasher what a great day um what
were the highlights in that section
before we start talking
about uh edge runners
yeah the atom smasher thing is actually
interesting because it kind of feeds
into the brain dance stuff i'm
interested to see how that character
carries on or appears in that game um
during the section that they show him
walking towards
a elevator you are actually in a brain
dance at that time
um and the person who is seeing adam
smasher
actually gets scared and when you're
reliving that brain dance as
v you feel that fear which is an
interesting
kind of layered thing so when this
happens in the game
the character you're inhabiting is a
woman and you can feel her
or they they through the presentation
show that she's scared
and then that feeling of fear lingers
with v so there's an interesting kind of
like um
a lingering effect of what you do and
the emotions and the feelings you have
in a brain dance that kind of
can carry into the real life in the game
so we'll see what that means narratively
and in terms of characterization for
v and doing these brain dances um but
yeah that section is really really cool
um it's it's it's like one of the things
that we talked about earlier an
unexpected part of the cyberpunk
gameplay experience
um the investigative stuff and and that
kind of business is something that i'm
super into so i'm
i think that looks that stuff look
really cool
yeah that's actually a very nice segue
into the braindance
segment i mean i
genuinely hadn't i deliberately didn't
speak to you guys about what you'd seen
um just so that i would be kind of fresh
to it and
i expected you to be able to play those
sequences i didn't realize there would
be that level of detail where it is like
a batman
arkham origins kind of the crime scene
investigation rewinding positioning uh
similar from arkham knight to
that was really really cool um
i wonder like how much of the plot is
going to be
in these brain dance segments uh
jake did you get any indication not
really i actually
didn't have a chance to check out the
brain dance sections because i spent
more time messing around
but one thing that uh ed said when we
were
doing our impressions he said it remind
him a lot of tacoma i don't know if you
guys played that but
uh i can definitely see it watching the
gameplay and how
you're basically rewinding and replaying
specific
sections and you're trying to key in on
specific items and figure out details
uh and you know you know i think it's
kind of neat to see
that sort of system from a very small
indie game in this like giant aaa
game um not that they necessarily not
they necessarily stole that idea or you
know took reference from it
but uh it's just interesting to see
i love this guy because he basically
looks like octane from uh
yeah yeah this this actually
this i was going to say this this uh
braindance section
is is a tutorial for the the actual
gameplay mechanic
and it involves these two characters
holding up the store
and at the end of it the person holding
up the store dies
and the tutorial is a kind of
investigation into how this character or
this
robber gets killed because it's
uncertain so they use this as a it's a
really interesting little setup and they
use this as to teach the player about
how brain dances work
and then they very quickly become more
elaborate from this point on i got to do
two
during my playthrough and this was the
simpler of the two the other one was
shortly after adam smasher gives you the
dirty look in the elevator
what was that one like can you describe
it so that one was
actually a the atom smasher post adam
smasher one was
a part of a heist that you are planning
for
so the the whole point of a brain dance
is it like they said in the in the
actual
gameplay demo it captures a scene a
memory and recreates it for others to
experience
usually gets used for pornography but
certain characters like judy
alvarez i think her name was she's able
to edit them and recreate them so you
can
relive them outside of pony reasons
um and so you're as v you're scouting
out this
um this this apartment because it
belongs to the son
of uh one of the mega corporations that
controls the night city
and this person has a special piece of
technology that you want to steal
and what you have to do is the person
you're
living the the uh the the memory as
is someone that has a close relationship
with this uh this person um let's call
it
and you are reliving the memory so you
can investigate the room
see what its layout is try and figure
out where the item you want to steal is
placed
listen to the conversation maybe get an
idea of what his plans are
and and kind of generally build a
foolproof
heist before you actually go in there
and do it yourself
um and it's really really interesting
because it was more elaborate than the
liquor store hold up one but it's still
quite maintained quite limited in in
in kind of like how it played out the uh
character um would just
move uh across a room and you'd just
kind of track him and listen in on his
conversation
and then you'd switch like a heat
signature um layer and try and find out
where the
item is is located because it needed to
be super cool so you're looking for the
coldest spot in the room
um so it was part of the the kind of
like build up towards making it more
complex but it still hit that kind of um
i'm an
investigator and i'm figuring something
out um
pleasure node in the brain that people
get out of these kind of experiences
um so it was it was fun and it was
intricate and
interesting in a way that you know is a
nice refreshing change of pace from the
usual shooting sneaking of the main game
um all right so i think in terms of the
first night city wire presentation
there wasn't you know a keanu moment
there wasn't a grimes moment
there was an anime moment so i'm gonna
go to our resident anime expert
jake what did you think of the anime
reveal
i'll pass it on to two more no i'm just
kidding
i i i'm very excited to see what this
will be
i will definitely watch it just because
i'm
very into cyberpunk not super into anime
uh but we'll see maybe maybe this will
this will change my mind i know studio
trigger like them doing this is a very
big deal
uh and they have made some very good
anime but i
couldn't tell you what that is so i
think uh i think timur is going to have
to uh
teach us teach me a lesson here
uh i think we should clip out that that
moment where jake says i'm very excited
for anime for annex
just where we have it for theory yeah
studio trigger one of the most
uh you know talented animation studios
in the world
definitely in japan um known for animes
like
killer kill mainly and recently they put
out pome
um in in in kind of uh cinemas and
both critically acclaimed they have
other stuff that they've done as well
little witch academia
and and uh guren lagann i think was them
as well
um but they are a fantastic animation
studio they have a very distinct
style that works really really well with
um
kind of cyberpunk uh and they
they've been it's coming out in 2022
which means and and everything that's
happening in here is a
it's got it takes place in night city
and shares the world of cyberpunk but
a unique story unique characters which
is incredibly exciting they've shown off
one
teaser image which is like a kid who
looks like
um a character out of a killer kill or
grand like i'm just kind of peering over
shoulder and wearing the iconic jacket
and it looks awesome i think the thing
that
kind of takes it to the next level is
the music is actually being done by
akira yamaoka
who is the composer behind silent hill
and
and various entries in the silent hill
franchise and
just an absolute like legend in the
gaming industry so the fact that we've
got studio trigger
teaming up with akira yamaka to make a
cyberpunk anime
is pretty exciting um it's coming to
netflix in 2022
um which means we'll probably be done by
the game by then
so perfect timing
all right that just about wraps it up uh
jake any more final comments on what we
saw this morning or what you had
hands on with uh
huh there was something that i had in my
head a while ago but i forgot what it
was that i wanted to say
welcome back to smoover smooth genitals
because i i i went into the general
section as well
and um immediately you can change your
general size you can pick your general
type or you could just get rid of it
so i did the smooth boy just to um
just to see what was that like and it
was it's absolutely fine
no issues
yeah the candle you can you can pick
your size
if you want to um yeah
i don't know if i don't know if that
it's going to become visible at any
point my hope is that you are
i think it will walk around
no there is you can you can get sex
wreckers you can
hook up with people i fully anticipate
there's gonna be nudity in this i
i
i'm changing my run to a stealth no kill
fully nude run
so um it's gonna be exciting you can
watch the stream of it on twitch.tv
gamespot that's not happening by the way
i said i'm fine
i've already put it in my calendar i
really want to see it uh
jake is that thought come back to you
uh i mean one thing that that i thought
was pretty funny was the story that i
bought the knife from was called second
amendment
um i guess another thing
that was kind of cool was the the nomad
path started out in the badlands
and seeing that seeing what's outside of
night city was really awesome um
and i'm excited to check out the other
life paths and i guess the other thing
to bring up is that we are
going to be doing a q a video next week
so if you have any questions for us
about cyberpunk and what we played make
sure to
uh tweet it either myself tomorrow or
edmund tran because we're gonna get back
together
and try to answer all the questions that
you guys might have
keep in mind that we did only play four
hours and it was very early in the game
so we didn't see a whole lot um but
there's still a lot to talk about
getting the band back together for your
q a
all right we're gonna uh we're gonna
show
the video of your impressions um so kind
of more in-depth chat about what you
guys played
featuring all the new gameplay uh thank
you for joining us this morning
um and we'll be back again next time
there is a night city wire
play for all streams we're doing charity
streams every day and
we will see you next time hey everyone
the three of us just played four hours
of cyberpunk each we all pick different
life paths and we all played slightly
differently in this video we're gonna go
over
what differences we encountered during
our play demo so let's start with
ed so i went with corpo it starts off
with you throwing up in a sync
and your initial story is um
you're a counterintelligence operative
and your boss
wants to sort of take down his boss
unfortunately
um the higher ups get wind of it and you
end up getting your life to
basically like taunt to shreds like all
of your money like all of your like
insurance
your entire life that's been supported
by this corporate job of yours
is gone and you end up on the street
basically from
uh starting from scratch you're already
friends with uh your partner jackie at
this point
and so he kind of helps you out and
helps you get back on your feet
and then tomorrow you picked the street
rat or the street
kid street kid yeah i'm so my one i
start off in a
bar um and the street kid has got some
connections and it's like
street street weary and wiley and
is uh from night city or
treats it like home and helps out one of
the bartenders at the bar
who's got a ongoing debt towards one of
the fixers
and he kind of asks you to go speak to
the fixer and try and
help out and alleviate or get his debt
settled entirely
so you go and do that and you have an
argument with this fixer who's an
out-of-towner and you kind of throw your
weight around as a local
he shows you like there's some magazine
and there's a sports car on there and
he's like steal that sports car it's top
of the line
it'll clear the debt so you go over you
get pointed to the right direction by
his inside man
and then you start stealing um and the
moment you start
getting the car like this hand comes
through the window and tells you to get
out
and obviously you kind of like pull away
and try to use the device
the device doesn't work you get pulled
out of the car you're about to get
beaten up but then the cops show up
and they kind of put both of you to the
ground and then someone like an elite or
one percenter shows up and it's like
it's not worth wasting your time
throw them both out and so you get
chucked out onto the street the person
who pulled you out of the car
was jackie and he's like that's how you
meet
i was told there's a montage that shows
your progression through the years it
wasn't
actually in our my demo um i'm not sure
if it was any of yours but
effectively it's kind of like a we were
told like a an animated sequence of some
sort
um or a cinematic sequence that kind of
shows that you guys stuck together for a
while did a bunch of jobs you had a
history and then you pick up with the
main story yeah so i played the nomad
path
and the nomad path begins with your
character v
tearing off the i don't know the the
badge
of their clan and heading into night
city in order to smuggle something into
the city
and your car breaks down in this small
town out way outside of night city in
this desert town
and you're trying to repair your car you
repair your car to meet your contact
who has the thing that you're trying to
smuggle in turns out to be jackie
you meet him talk with him a little bit
and then you and jackie head to the
border
where you have to get out of the car and
they do an inspection
uh and you have to talk to a uh i guess
a border agent
i would say and they ask you some
questions
hop back in the car and then as you're
driving
there's a roadblock that they've set up
and then there's a fire fight that
happens and
eventually that section ends and then
apparently we'd get the cut scene too
that would lead you into how the game
starts and then once you've done those
introductions it sounds like
the game for the most part is very
similar like all three paths kind of
merged
now sit down and tell me what's got your
shorts in a knot
it's good to see you too jack how you
been so
with that out of the way how did you
guys play
i i like to speak into like handguns
specifically um
handguns and melee and stealth
and i found that i ended up relying on
my handgun a lot
because given that this is so early in
the game a lot of the stealth skills
that are actually useful aren't
available to you unless you unlock them
as perks
so i found myself failing stealth a lot
and ending up in a lot of firefights
yeah so i i put together one of the
classic like i don't know what i'm doing
trash bills
where i like i was just like oh how do i
usually play and
i i didn't learn the lesson that ed
clearly did very quickly so
obviously ed is always smarter than me
um but like i did the thing where i
expect him to stealth and spec into cool
and body so i was like
i can be sneaky and i can talk my way
out of things and
have a bit of charisma obviously i
didn't think about the fact that it
would take a while for that to come into
full effect
so i ended up being a kind of a
run-and-gun kick the door in type person
who is clearly incapable of doing it
because i'm respect towards stealth
so i created like a bumbling idiot of a
v but
it still it didn't lock me out of
anything i was still quite capable like
in firefights i was winning
it's important to know that if you do
pick up something that's not in your
wheelhouse you can still get better at
it by just doing the thing
so if if i like i didn't have any
shotgun skills at all
but if i picked up a shotgun and started
shooting it a bunch you would rank up
with the gun and
yeah it's it's kind of like skyrim where
the thing you do
you get better it's funny you mentioned
the cool thing because when i created my
character i dumped all my points into
cool right away
and the person i was playing with the
dev was like may not want to do that
and i was like oh okay and i was like
well what if i want to play like a net
runner so he
had me spec into intelligence and
i think technical ability was what it
was called but what i found out too is
cool is connected to stealth and i ended
up using a lot of stealth because
kind of like your guy's experience i
ended up being trash at net running just
because i didn't really have many
abilities unlocked and
i imagine that's gonna be a similar sort
of experience for most people who start
this game
maybe not so much using firearms but i
think you're gonna spec into something
and then as you play you're going to
figure out how you actually want to
play at least early on it's important to
note that we've played the first four or
five hours of the game of like what is
going to be like a 50 60 hour game
so a lot of the stuff that really will
matter in the end um
doesn't really come into play so like in
in the cool perk system there's like a
it's like a cold blood like uh ability
so when you like get
super cool you have like uh buffed
abilities and that kind of stuff yeah i
i
the small amounts of stealth that i did
manage to pull off was
quite interesting because it was like a
mixture of my stealth movement and also
using the
netrunner stuff um like hacking into a
camera i
i didn't realize that when you hack into
a camera they're very threatening those
cameras because they fire out
laser beams and like it blankets the
entire thing and they move around and i
was like
damn how do i even begin to do this and
i didn't realize that actually when you
hack into a camera you effectively take
it over and it's yours
but it doesn't change the red laser into
green to be like hey
you're green now it's good now it's a
good laser yeah it's a good laser so
like doing the small amounts of
i'm sneaking hacking that thing using it
to distract enemies
the way like the two different divergent
styles of play kind of
meshed together was really interesting
so i'm looking forward to see how they
can be paired up with like you know
netrunners ability hacking abilities
with the stealth and then stealth's
abilities kind of complemented by the
you know powerful gun kind of like spec
and that kind of stuff
that was the one thing almost every
encounter i started out by hacking into
the local network or whatever it might
be and once you do that
you it basically when it highlights all
the different things you can hack which
i think because i was pretty early
i wasn't able to hack a lot but there
were like fans i could hack
to distract enemies there were cameras
you could hack
you could hack certain npcs too to get
other npcs to come by you could hack
grenades to make them explode
okay so we've talked about playstyle
we've talked about origin how about how
you guys just
kind of played this demo there was a lot
we could do they didn't really put any
restrictions
on us at all in terms of what we could
do uh
so how did you guys spend your four
hours my one was probably the most plain
playthrough in that i
jumped into it and just kind of followed
the main path and
quickly realized that it was a familiar
path i talk about this in my written
preview but it's it's the
a lot of it was the missions that we saw
in the
um gameplay demos from the past two
years obviously this is the first time
we've actually played it for ourselves
i think the actual main path at least to
start with is a really good um
example of the different facets of the
gameplay mechanics like
that first mission you do with um for
dexter desean
you get a good flavor of what is hacking
like what is
uh combat like what is sneaking like and
you can start to figure out
i like i've got a feel for the hacking i
really like that so i'm gonna expect
towards that um and then i
use the kind of final moments to try and
find
some some like side quests that were
interesting the side quests are what
everyone loves from witcher so i wanted
one of those at least and i found that
yeah i mean i probably
took the exact opposite approach in that
i didn't even really do side quests i
just roamed the world
and messed around like the first thing i
did when i got out of these apartment is
i took i bought a knife
from uh the store called 21st amendment
and stabbed the cop because
i don't know he was out there and i want
to see what would happen which is
something different from the witcher 3
right because well a there's no cops but
also
you can't just start destroying a town
in the witcher right because geralt is
this character who wouldn't do that
but in this uh you have that freedom i
gotta
i forget how much the warrant was and
then it was i got a
notification saying the the ncpd are now
after me
and that was pretty interesting just
because i don't know immediately i
thought of gta
yeah like big gta vibes coming from this
game
uh you can also help the cops too like
you can go past
like a hold up or something and help him
out there are a lot of incidental things
happening in the city that you can just
join in on
in fact the incidental stuff reminds me
a lot of red dead like you'd just be
walking around and there'd be a
firefight between cops and gangs and you
could
help out one of the sides you could just
walk away or sometimes there'd just be a
bunch of guys guarding
a cache or something and you could go in
kill them take it or occasionally with
your when you get your upgraded eye
i forget what they call it your upgraded
vision yeah
you can actually see if there's a
warrant out on npcs or
and you can just examine them and if you
see warren out on this arrest for this
amount you can kill him and you'll
automatically get that money transferred
into your account i i mentioned this to
jake earlier but i was doing some of
that kind of exploring and
found an incidental thing which was a
gang
fighting each other a couple of gangs
and i was like i'm just going to check
this out in the moment i realized i
should probably get on with my
my actual quest is when one of them
threw a grenade at another one another
one and missed completely and the
grenade just landed at my feet and i was
like
i'm i'm not here for this i'm out after
hearing about tomorrow's experience
i wanted to go see a lot more side
quests um but i think
given that this is so early in the game
and the game actually does want
to put you through those main quests to
get the breath of experience
there weren't that many other proper
side missions that i could do
the side quests that i did find did
look at sort of the kookya nature of
like the cyberpunk world
so one had you get into like a fight
club situation with these
twins who had uh merged their
consciousnesses to be
one person um and there's a lot of like
funny banter between them and like
stuff about them showing girlfriends and
that kind of stuff and basically you
just had to fight them both at once
and then there was another one where a
guy's
augmented penis had gone haywire and you
had to
rush him to the ripper dock basically
and like there's a whole bunch of
car badger in between there and so
that's that's kind of the the world
they're trying to set up and it's it's
not all like
grim dark uh cyberpunk stuff there is a
bit of a lot of levity in there
i think the most interesting thing for
me is how much the corpora stuff
played into the main quest since my
character came from a corporate
background
like there's that whole thing where one
of your uh contacts
uh sets you up she gives you like a like
a credit shipped with a virus to like um
like sabotage the the marauders uh
basically
if you take the corporate path your
character basically knows all the [ __ ]
that she's gonna pull
you can just call her out on it and just
yeah just
basically you are in the position of
power there um
which i found quite interesting when i
did that i i decided to ignore
her completely so the in the original
demos they do that bit where they go to
her
get the chip and then go to the
maelstrom gang and eventually things
kick off so i was like i'm gonna
just ignore that because i want to get
into it as quick as possible
um and the first thing i do when i meet
with the bad guy
uh is is or the gang leader is
shoot him in the head and kill him like
straight away because it's like
um you don't have the money to do
anything else or your choices are either
to kill him or
get killed um and that knock-on effect
is in the original
when you did the kind of corporate as
well
that dude would get away and then come
back later with his exoskeleton
and fight you this time around because
he was dead there was just no one in
that area like there was two guards who
are just like knocked out
i was like i'm out um so like there is
there's like very
noticeable changes to what happens in a
mission depending on how
you do them in my playthrough i could
not
focus on the main path at all like
almost every
every corner i turned i was like oh this
looks interesting and i'd get out and
check it out just because the world is
so dense
but i found one small alley that opened
up into this
huge market place area where there are
all these characters wandering around
like it was packed
and there was a guy on the corner who
was like you know
he's a sidewalk preacher yelling about
how cybernetics
are destroying people in the next
generation needs to stop
cybering up their bodies so they can so
they can continue to live
and and whatnot and i was watching him
for a little bit because i was just like
yeah sure
and two like trendy looking girls walked
up with phones
and immediately started like oh this is
the crazy guy everyone's been talking
about like
like let's get some pictures of them and
they start like taking selfies with them
and whatnot and he just keeps yelling
about it and he's getting frustrated and
i'm just sitting here watching this
whole thing play out it is a very dense
and distracting world
and trying to block all that out and
actually look at the city for what the
city is
like is is very nice like i really
appreciated how
sort of it was built it's very it's got
a lot of verticality to it a lot of
stairs and like twisty pathways
there's like a lot of dead areas of the
city if you know what i mean like
because there are a lot of freeways
intersecting so there's obviously going
to be the quieter areas of the city
places that are a bit uglier yeah
because like it it makes the parts
are bustling feel a little more real
when the stuff there's areas that are on
like i had this one interaction which
stuck out to me
which i'm not sure if it was an accident
but i hope it wasn't but like
i was walking and i kind of drifted into
a an area of the pavement where there
was a cop nearby and he did not want me
to be there
and he very aggressively shouted like
back up
but next to me was a i'm not body
shaming or anything like that a very
large man
was next to me and i don't know what
happened but like
he freaked out and just started running
and i was like okay i'm just gonna
follow this guy
and i followed this guy for a while and
he just kept running
and it wasn't like he was just running
in a straight line he was
he looked like he was going somewhere
and i was like i asked the developer i
was like is this
does this dude have a story and he was
like i'm not sure
um and i wanted to follow him because he
looked terrified and he just
he was like running his i don't know how
he had that much stamina but i was like
if this was if this was like my natural
play through i think i would follow him
for about 15 to 20 minutes just to see
what would happen
but i think something else that really
stuck out that stuck out to me was the
brain dance mechanic did you guys try
that
i did not know yeah so that's something
i didn't really know about i've been
kind of limiting how much i see but
like at the risk of being reductive it's
the uh detective mode investigation
stuff from batman arkham origins
um i like to compare it to you did you
guys play tacoma
the follow-up to god that's exactly what
it reminded me of so just having a scene
play out in 3d space but you
are free to move around and look at the
other nooks and crannies not in the main
scene
so the idea is people are effectively
taking their memories
and um recreating them almost like
in a video editing suite and then
selling them on for various things
most of the time it's used for you know
adult entertainment but you can do weird
things with it and you can also do
things like
put yourself into another person's
memory and explore it
and you can do that via first person or
you can detach and just watch it all
play out
and then there's like wrinkles like um
using
just focusing on an audio layer in the
actual environment and listening to key
conversations
they show you how it works by making you
live through a failed
hold up scene where one person is
whether you're perpetrators
killed and you figure out why that
happened and how that happened and it's
just a really cool
wrinkle that makes me that makes me
excited about the potential for like
future cop like the example that they
gave us obviously very early and very
linear
and i kind of am curious to see whether
the story changes based on what you do
or don't pick up like if you go into a
brain dance and don't pick up a clue
uh what happens then yeah it's
impressive right
it's too bad most of the bds we do here
are only good for flogging the log
in a lot of ways it does feel like an
overall rpg that
you know players will probably be very
familiar with yeah and it's more
more like in-depth in the witcher was
by design so like when i went into the
actual like
skill tree menu i was like wow this is a
lot and they were and the developer that
was on call was like
yeah people kind of felt like there
wasn't a lot of freedom to
create their own kind of geralt they
have buckets of like you know
cool and body and you know tech and that
kind of stuff but with the in those
there's like multiple skill trees that
have so many
different small options to unlock like
passives and abilities and that kind of
stuff and for those that want it i did
double check and
it seemed that the developer on our on
my playthrough was like you can do a no
kill run of the game
so that's what i'll be doing well anyway
those are our impressions of cyberpunk
2077 we have a ton of cyberpunk
content planned and already up so make
sure to check all that stuff out on
gamespot and if you have any questions
for us we will be doing a q
a next week where we will answer your
questions so if you have anything for us
please leave them in the comments below
or you can find us on twitter and we
will try to get to all those questions
next time
anyway thank you so much for watching
and we'll see you later
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
you